une nouvelle génération de véhicule
électrique verra peut-être bientôt le
jour au québec la compagnie électrique
lions six autres entreprises et le
gouvernement du québec investit près de
16 millions dans l'électrification des
transports
l'objectif est de développer une variété
de camions électriques un camion de
marchandises un camion atelier un camion
nacelle un camion collecte une ambulance
ces véhicules seront entièrement conçu
et fabriqué au québec avec nous marc
bédard président fondateur de la
compagnie électrique lyon bonsoir on se
montre c'est fini est ce que vous êtes
les seuls au monde à développer ce type
de camion lourd et d'ambulances
électrique
je me garde une petite gêne en dix ans
le seul au monde
on sait qu'on est le seul en amérique du
nord
oui et on pense qu'on est récent
normande aujourd'hui elle a développé
cette dalle développer ce type de camion
l'a donc parlez nous de ces camions
électriques de ce châssis sur lequel il
repose comment ça fonctionne
en fait ce champ si électrique là il
serait ailleurs au monde également sur
un camion qui peut exister à d'autres
endroits
la grande particularité de ce qu'ont
fait premièrement c'est un camion
relativement un camion 100% électrique
la grande particularité maintenance et
l'intégration de ces équipements qui
sont des équipements électriques sur un
camion 100% électrique et donc avec avec
d'autres équipements qu'on retrouve dans
les voitures traditionnelles vont dans
les camions traditionnels exactement
donc ce sont des équipements par exemple
hydro québec
voilà un équipement donc exemple une
nacelle qu'hydro québec utilisent des
gens et avec 1 1
une optimisation de l'électrification
cette nacelle l'homme maintenant vont
être installés et et écrire sur notre
camion 100% électrique et la
particularité en fait c'est que
l'énergie la venelle à 100% du camion
donc systèmes auxiliaires d'énergie et
qu'ils demanderaient qui est que la
nacelle à ce moment là pourrait utiliser
tout ou par de l'énergie de camions là
ce moment le pot
l'opérateur c'est beaucoup plus facile
ça fait combien d'années vous travailler
là dessus parce que vous fabriquez aussi
des autobus électriques qu'ils sont ce
type de camion l'a en fait sur le camion
comme tel sur environ quatre ans et sur
ces types
autrement dit sur cette intégration
d'équipements spécialisés saf environ
deux ans c'est important quand même
parce que quand on regarde les camions
lourds qu'ils occupaient à peu près la
moitié du trafic routier n'est ce pas et
qui émettent beaucoup de gaz à effet de
serre nécessairement donc vous vous le
présenter comme étant une vraie bonne
solution écologique sur nos routes
en fait c'est une vraie solution
écologie c'est un camion comme ceux
normalement vont émettre ou au diésel
d'un camion au diesel vont mettre une
centaine de tonnes de gaz à effet de
serre par année
oui donc c'est beaucoup au juste en
électrifiant un pourcentage des camions
des autobus
le gouvernement du québec pourrait
atteindre son objectif de réduction des
gaz à effet de serre d'ici 2030 et même
en incluant le cycle de vie du véhicule
absolument soit il ya eu beaucoup de mes
informations là-dessus mais tout à fait
parce que on sait que les batteries vont
prendre environ 25 ans avant d'être
recyclées 25 ans ça veut dire environ
dizaine d'années en utilisation optimale
après ça environ cinq années en
utilisation secondaire et une troisième
vie va être comme une utilisation
exemple pour une génératrice donc une
utilisation stationnaire et vous
travaillez avec des partenaires
québécois quand on dit que c'est 100 %
électrique tous les partenaires du
québec leçons du québec c'est 100 %
québécois les partenaires avec qui vous
travaillez en fait on a la chance
d'avoir des partenaires extraordinaire
ils ont été triés sur le volet ce sont
des leaders dans chacun de leurs deux
mains je pense à 2 mars par exemple
d'aller dans les habits là c'est bien
connu
le maire s'est connus vous envoyer
depuis 60 ans donc demers investi dans
le groupe actuellement en fait
l'investissement total du projet ses 16
millions de dollars et chacun des
partenaires sont en blanc à l'intérieur
donc effectivement les ambulances
représente plusieurs millions en
développement parce que demers une
entreprise comme demers investi dans le
développement mais va acheter de ces
ambulances les calebasses absolument en
prison les vendre donc ce qu'ils vont
les vendre à une grâce qui deviennent
partenaires c'est ça du groupe de
fabrication haut depuis la même chose
avec chacun des partenaires en fait ce
qui se passe et que deux forces de vente
et à la force de vent client est
à force de vente du partenaire dont d'un
code demers que vous parlez et ils y ont
déjà toutes leurs forces de vente et
parfois des concessionnaires également
en amérique du nord
ils vont vendre le produit nous allons
rendre le produit également donc on fait
avec des équipes comme le disait le
ministre ce matin
l'union fait la force oui exactement là
vous êtes en fabrication de ces camions
lourds électrique en fait possible avec
les équipements spécialisés ces exemples
hydro québec
oui annoncé ce matin la chaux du premier
camion nacelle 100% électrique ils en
achètent un anneau château de commencer
ces contrats s'il faut me contre 8 unis
verizon à décembre 2020 décembre 2020
est ce que vous avez d'autres contrats
d'autres clients comme ça on a un
contrat pour les bennes à collecte de
déchets avec un très important client
américain qui a demandé où en ce moment
de garder la confidentialité de son nom
donc je peux vous et qui ont acheté 2
hockey et ça va être annoncée dans les
prochaines semaines et c'est quoi vos
objectifs on est objectif est grandiose
en fait l usine de saint jérôme
on a 1000 on est en capacité de
production de 1000 unités et on aimerait
que cette capacité là soient dépassées
dans les trois prochaines années vont
être dépassés donc les 1000 unités donc
ça va prendre plus de contrôle bien sûr
plus de clients oui exactement donc on
voudrait donc ses mille d'unités par
année donc on voudrait devoir agrandir
l'usiné dans trois ans ou bien de voir
construire une deuxième mise avez-vous
tout la main d'oeuvre nécessaire
absolument pas non non oui besoin de
combien vous avez des postes ouverts
c'est ça on a des postes ouverts en ce
moment on cherche en ce moment une
quarantaine d'ingénieurs et on cherche
une cinquantaine de personnes sur les
lignes de production
donc en fait c'est un milieu vraiment
rien parce que c'est l'électrification
des transports
les jeunes aiment venir travailler on a
une superbe équipe et l'on tente de
trouver des façons également quelques de
plus en plus de gens qui soient attirés
venez travailler chez dior ça fonctionne
assez bien jusqu'à date
bombay le messager lançant tout comme
monsieur bédard merci bonne chance merci
à vous